en la capital francesa miles de personas
se manifestaron en contra de las medidas
del gobierno galo para contrarrestar la
propagación del cob y 19 una de las más
controvertidas es la discusión del
proyecto de emergencia que pretende
reemplazar el pase sanitario en un pase
vacunal y que limitaría el acceso a
sitios comerciales el transporte público
a quienes no cuenten con el esquema de
vacunación completo
no queremos un pase para nuestros hijos
por un virus que al final les tiene poco
impacto no le veo sentido les priva de
su libertad la medida fundamental del
proyecto de ley tiene como que tubo
persuadir a los cerca de 5 millones de
personas mayores de 12 años que aún no
se han inmunizado para que se vacunen
qué voy a hacer bueno me he contagiado
de ccoo vidas y que tengo un pase de
momento estoy bien y después me las
arreglaré no es el fin del mundo si no
voy al restaurante
[Aplausos]
las protestas se suceden en un complejo
contexto se registran el mismo día que
se actualizaron los lineamientos para
que el pase sanitario sea válido a
partir de este sábado serán desactivados
son los pases de quienes hayan dejado
pasar más de siete meses sin haber
recibido su dosis de refuerzo contra el
kobe 19 la determinación del presidente
macrón ante el tema de los anti vacunas
es total a principio de mes declaró al
diario le parisien que iba a fastidiar a
quienes se oponen a las inyecciones